en octobre dernier la productrice de
dindon Marie-Christine parent a dû faire
rabattre 11500 oiseaux à cause de
l'agrippe aviaire
pour éviter le retour du virus la
productrice a nettoyé ses poules et à
faire remplacer les planchers
sont pas changés je peux pas avoir
l'approbation du nettoyage complété ce
qui m'empêche de passer à l'étape de
désinfection la production devrait donc
reprendre en janvier prochain
près de chez elle un producteur a fait
euthanasier 45000 poulets et 30 000
poules pondeuses et tout récemment en
Colombie-Britannique 14 fermes ont été
infectées en une semaine à l'Agence
canadienne d'inspection des aliments la
coordination des mesures d'urgence et
complexes on est dans une situation où
le virus est exceptionnel on n'a jamais
vu ça avant depuis un an un nombre sans
précédent d'oiseaux d'élevage et abattus
50 millions aux États-Unis 20 millions
en France
en Vendée dimanche fausses temporaire
ont été creusées par les autorités
sanitaires pour enfouir les carcasses
les centres d'équarrissage étant
complètement débordés des producteurs
doivent euthanasier eux-mêmes leur
volaille on nous a dit un peu en off
vous fermez la ventilation de votre
bâtiment toute une nuit et après vous
ramassez les cadavres dans les jours qui
suivent et comme au Canada de nouveaux
foyers d'éclosion apparaissent depuis
l'automne en France les éleveurs ne sont
pas au bout de leur peine selon ce
spécialiste des maladies aviaires ça
devrait diminuer avec l'arrivée de
l'hiver et puis au printemps prochain on
est à très haut risque que ça prenne
éleveur et scientifiques cherchent un
remède efficace la vaccination est
envisagée les grands pays exportateurs
de volaille l'interdisent mais l'ampleur
de la crise actuelle change la donne et
des projets pilotes de vaccination sont
en cours en Europe ici France Baudouin
Radio-Canada Québec